hello and welcome to fantasy week over
here at bleacher report my name is ian
hardin's lead fantasy expert over at pro
football focus here to talk through 10
fancy stars that i'm fading at adp this
season before we get into that though
just wanted to give you guys a quick
injury update around the league as we
know we've had actual live football
being played unfortunately with that
these damn injury gods gotta have a
thing or two to say so with that in mind
san francisco 49ers drawing back elijah
mitchell dealing with a hamstring injury
that will keep him out for the preseason
has him set to go for week one but as we
know with these types of things we will
see it when we believe it right now jeff
wilson is probably the number two
running back based on how they're
resting their guys in the preseason also
keep an eye on trey sermon who had
had 11 snaps alongside trey lance with
the starters in preseason week one also
got a look at that seattle seahawks
backfield we're gonna be talking about
them a lot more later but just realize
right now rashad penny actually trending
upwards back to practice after suffering
that groin injury not the same though
with kenneth walker unfortunately going
through hernia issues and even had a
procedure yesterday pete carroll tells
us that they're hopeful he'll be ready
week one one of the tougher coaches out
there to truly be trusting on that front
though a couple more small things james
robinson coming back from the achilles
and what an incredible story that is
like science people how great is this
with robinson already off the pup list
and doug peterson confirmed he is in
fact expecting to be back there week one
so i still think we'll see plenty of uh
travis etienne out there expecting kind
of a detroit lions de'andre swift jamal
williams type of rotation with those
running backs but either way great to
see j rob nearing a return to the
football field also got giovanni bernard
small ankle juju smith schuster small
knee miko harmon small groin issue none
of those are considered overly serious
so with that everyone let's get into
today's main event again talking to top
10 fantasy stars i'm going to be fading
at adp i can't stress this enough it's
at adp i do not believe in the idea of
just completely fading someone not
drafting someone for no reason at all so
even though i'm going to list some guys
that are good football players i'm not
saying you can't draft them just that i
wouldn't at their present consensus adp
with that said number ten
dallas cowboys tight end dalton schultz
he's my tight end six and he's going off
the board as the titan six in most
drafts the problem is where he's going
overall my 86 player overall adp 57
player overall once you look through the
draft and when you kind of get going
you're gonna notice real quickly that
rounds five and six are the best spots
to take quarterbacks we have guys like
jalen hurts kylo murray even lamar
jackson sometimes sliding all the way
down there and that's been my favorite
range to try to get one of those high
upside talents you lose that edge if you
take dalton schultz right there in the
middle of round five so i get it he is
one of the only six tight ends last year
to average at least 12 ppr points per
game very well could be the number two
in dallas but we have dallas goddard who
is every bit as talented if not more i
would actually definitely consider
dallas goddard a superior real life
tight end to doubt to uh schultz i don't
think the target discrepancy is all that
great and dallas goddard is going a full
20 picks later than dalton schultz again
don't hate the player hate the adp i'm
much more willing to just get guys like
mike williams like cortland sutton like
jerry judy in the fifth and sixth rounds
if i'm not getting the quarterback and
then hang him back later to get dallas
goddard because i do not think that
dalton shoal should be priced closer to
teren waller than he is to dallas
goddard which is the case right now
appreciate you guys there in the chat we
got andrew nichols avoiding keenan allen
for sure hey man it maybe could be the
mike williams takeover i will say at
cost right now and it's tough with the
adps because we all i'm sure a lot of
you still haven't had your fantasy
drafts yet and that's reflected with a
lot of the consensus adps we see versus
like best ball and sharp leagues with
guys who have been doing this all summer
so keenan is going about wide receiver
12 and both the differences mike
williams is going around wide receivers
16 17 and some of these home leagues
going bind receiver 13 right next to
keenan and sharper league so at cost i
do like mike williams more than keenan
from sean uh shawneel michael pittman
going to be insane this year you are
right he is my pick for this season's
like let's see we've had chris goblin
calvin ridley and deonte johnson those
have been like the key third year
breakout wide receivers over the past
few years they flashed they got this
extra little target bump and michael
pittman's case getting a nice
quarterback bump love that call sean
also jay putra molly david johnson's a
sleeper maybe uh maybe a couple years
ago man i don't even think david
johnson's on a team at the moment we'll
see though can always change in a hurry
let's get to my number nine
uh fade you guys aren't gonna like this
one but hear me out san francisco 49ers
running back wide receiver debo samuel
we have as a society been now
conditioned to talk about the debose
samuel role with any wide receiver that
ever touches the ball as a rusher it's
not good guys we want targets we don't
want rush attempts targets historically
are worthy of about 2.7 rush attempts in
terms of our expected ppr points per
game the reason why debo was fine last
year in the second half of the season
when he was starting to use more running
back was because he was basically the
most efficient running back in the
entire league maybe that happens again
maybe debo samuel just is so freaking
good that his touch count doesn't really
matter but right now pff projects devos
samuel for just the 26th most targets
among all wide receivers at 112 total
pass game opportunities he's gonna run
first offense with a new quarterback who
let's face it we have some questions
about and i just think that when he's
sharing an offense with two guys as
talented as george kittle and brandon
ayoke we can see debo even though his
talent makes him a 1a sort of player he
could be in a three kind of player
committee of sorts in the passing game
and we also uncertain if we are getting
those running back carries now that the
running back room assuming mitchell's
hamstring is okay will be far healthier
come week one so debo samuel my wide
receiver 10 25th player overall right
now he's usually going off the board
wide receiver six 18th player overall if
diva falls into the third round fine go
for it i just see guys like alvin kamara
like saquon barkley three down workhorse
running backs available in round two
that i don't see in round three like to
me the difference between debo samuel
and someone like you know mike evans or
even you know kyle pitts if we really
get down the list just isn't worth it
with the running back value we still
have in round two
from romanov iowa will have a better
year than devo samuel bank on it it's
possible like last year clearly we were
all in the wrong on br brandon eye of
being ranked ahead of debo samuel this
year we've just completely reversed
course and again when you look at that
second half usage for debo he still
averaged 20 ppr points per game from
weeks 10 to through the nfc championship
but it was just 12.7 expected ppr points
per game he was at 17.1 expected ppr
points per game when he was playing the
wide receiver role so again is this one
of these things where we're using a top
20 pick on a guy we're trying to check
every box we want talent we want the
workload we want a great offense i'm not
convinced that devos workload is going
to be quite as good as these fellow
talented players also in great offenses
going around this range
also shout out darius p how do you feel
about tyrique this year good man and i
do feel a little bit better about
tyrique than devo because i'm just more
confident in miami embracing the passing
game and it is funny you know we're
always looking for who is going to be
this year's divo samuel tyree kill leads
the entire nfl and yards for carry since
he entered the league i know they're
different players debo you can actually
run between the tackles he's got that
extra weight on him but you know what in
the year 2022 i'm not so convinced that
we should be actually trying to find
players to run between the tackles
versus get them out in space like
tyrique
also shout out t-jack george pickens
gonna be that guy pal guys i got a text
from one of my close friends last night
where he legit asked me like should i
take pickens over deontay johnson that
is how crazy the hype has gotten at this
point pickens where he's usually going
in draft still certainly a fine late
round upside pick let's keep it moving
guys another player i'm gonna be fading
at adp we're about to go on a little
string of running backs here but las
vegas running back josh jacobs my rb 27
73rd player overall adp going rb 20 41st
player overall so you really are having
to spend a fourth round pick a lot of
times to get josh jacobs and i just
think that we are now going to view the
raiders as essentially new england like
southwest that's kind of what the
situation is going to be now with josh
mcdaniels running everything and if
we've learned one thing from trying to
figure out this new england backfield
over the years to set we usually know
nothing about it so some people look at
the fact that the raiders uh just
declined josh jacobs's fifth year option
as a sign it's just gonna run him into
the dirt in his final season i don't
think so guys they just signified they
don't want him around next year what did
josh mcdaniels do to add the backfield
he have he added a mirror abdullah they
drafted zamir white they even added
brandon bolton who shouldn't matter but
he does brandon bolden kept randre
stevenson and damon harris off the field
on pass downs last season mainstream
media wouldn't he wouldn't talk about it
but it was a reality and that's the kind
of just crazy stuff that happens in josh
mcdaniels and in the new england
backfield that's now what we're dealing
with with the raiders so honestly over
the years and it's like oh what about
josh jacobs and the damian harris with
the garrett blunt role what if he scores
15 touchdowns david harris last year
scored 15 touchdowns and was the rb 20
in ppr points per game the garrett blunt
season from 2016 rb15 and ppr points per
game it's silly to have the full point
per reception but it's the game we play
and it really hurts guys like josh
jacobs so i would much rather at this
point in the draft take one that many
upside wide receivers still available
i'm much more high on lower adp running
backs like cloud ever solaire cordero
patterson and miles sanders thanks to
their superior chances of catching the
ball
let's see here from zay divo's new
contract that was rushing incentives so
have a big year
again though we want targets guys not
not not rush attempts it's just way
easier for us remember you got to gain
10 rushing yards to just automatically
reach the amount of points you get for
just catching the ball those six inch
pop passes that jimmy g throws debo he
already has one fantasy point before he
even moves so it's just not fair to you
know it's not fair but it's a game we
play the great one should kamara be on
this list no we have gotten word now
from adam schefter that the expectation
is kamar will not be suspended until
2023 continue to lock him in as one of
the highest upside pass catching backs
in all of fantasy from hannah solomon
would you take aj brown or deontay
johnson i'm going with ajb just the
amount of money they got afforded to him
i do think devonte smith could be a
little more competition than he's had
throughout his career at the same time
deontay johnson has not only george
pickens but chase claypool is still
going to be there as well
it takes arms of manra should be a
second round pick guys i think if you
have a problem in your life the solution
should just always be draft of monroe st
brown like it just always makes my life
better i don't know about the second
round but i think rounds five or six if
i'm not taking a quarterback in that
range like i've been talking about a
monroe st brown a lot of times is that
guy all right another running back that
i don't like because he's in a committee
and he's probably not gonna catch passes
everyone's he's been dominating a
fantasy twitter this week washington
commanders running back antonio gibson
he's my rb 31 78th player overall at
this point adp still going off the board
rb 19 39th player overall it's just a
volume thing guys antonio gibson you
know tony paul or daryl henderson we've
seen these freaks that memphis has been
pushing out into the nfl over the years
and a lot of times they are kind of this
past catching running back wide receiver
hybrid that we get really excited about
and gibson has flashed down the stretch
of last season when mckissick had the
concussion we saw him actually go out
there and just be a great fantasy
running back even in a mediocre offense
the problem is mckissick went nowhere we
had that 12-hour period where he was on
the bills washington re-signed him and
what did they also do they drafted
alabama bruiser brian robinson in the
third round and he's already taking the
short down distance snaps away from
antonio gibson who also fumbled again in
the preseason usually drops and fumbles
i think we overrate these things they're
they can be fluky year to year
randomness and stuff but when gibson is
just fresh off leading the nfl and
fumbles and he does it immediately again
with more competition out there they're
now using him literally on special teams
during practice so antonio gibson as
someone that you know people will still
probably continue to reach on in that rb
dead zone period don't feel like you
need more running backs in rounds four
five six if you've taken a lot of wide
receivers do not reach on a player like
this again there's kareem hunt chase
edmunds cordaro patterson there are more
fantasy friendly running backs later
again the high upside wide receivers
even some of the tight ends quarterbacks
i'm taking all of them ahead of guys
like josh jacobs and antonio gibson at
this point in the draft
from cliffhanger miles miles sanders
should be in a void like if miles
sanders would go where antonio gibson
was i'd 100 agree with you man but miles
sanders is going right now pick 77th
overall so when i can get him four three
four rounds after antonio gibson that's
the thing man don't hate the player hate
the adp gibson's adp is much easier to
hate than miles sanders from at nick
what about nick chubb more on him in a
minute at donovan mcswag gibson should
be number one this list he lost his job
already it's not ranked in any
particular order it's just kind of going
from adp so don't worry about that from
app bill mcgee gibson is done uh done
for grab mckissick too full ppr i don't
hate mckissick but guys brian robinson
has the higher ceiling because think
about it if gibson i don't think he's
gonna get bent i think it's just gonna
be an annoying three running back
committee but if gibson gets hurt brian
robinson is the one who's adp is going
to rise he's going to be the one on all
the waiver wire articles you know the
following tuesday mckissick his role
just doesn't really change he's their
scat back which can be good in full ppr
but we're not gonna ever get a bunch of
carries
player number six chicago bears running
back david montgomery my rb 20 45th
player overall adp rb18 35th player
overall i draw a pretty clear line after
ezekiel elliott and bruce hall when i'm
looking at the running backs in these
drafts if i can get them in round four
sometimes cam akers falls i'm fine
getting those guys once it gets to david
montgomery he needs to fall past adp for
me to be comfortable taking a chance on
him we've already heard murmurs really
throughout the entire offseason about
khalil herbert turning this into more of
a committee situation you could argue
just what they were able to do last
season that herbert could even be the
superior running back from day one we
have a brand new coaching staff that's
going to be run by luke getze who's been
serving underneath the floor in green
bay for the last couple years and you
know if you just you watch aaron jones
for three seasons do the things he does
and you also watch the coach not give
him a featured role yeah i'm a little
bit worried about guessing doing the
same thing and not exactly featuring
dave montgomery here so again khalil
herbert we did see in the first week of
the preseason
like my biggest takeaways because i
don't care about you know the big plays
and stuff in the preseason but anytime
we can just help solidify some of the
depth charts going on that's really key
for me so there were three backup
running backs that played every single
snap with the starters niamh heinz and
indy which is very interesting alexander
madison in minnesota which given the new
coaching staff was a good sigh of relief
and then khalil herbert with the bears
did play every single snap alongside
justin fields with montgomery wrestling
so the fact they trust herbert across
all three downs i do think he has more
of a chance to make this a committee
situation i'm much more willing to take
a late round dart on khalil herbert as
opposed to reaching for montgomery in
round four
from matt swolo what do you think about
drafting zeke in round five i think it's
great again this is zeke in round five
it's don't let like last year's just
misses on fantasy guys like overly
influence you here and we'll we see it
all the time in twitter i'm not going to
draft zeke or no matter what or
christian mccaffrey is just going to get
hurt like when we can get that big of a
discount on ezekiel elliott like we're
not drafting zeke against top 12 players
anymore we're drafting him against top
50 guys so it's much it's a much easier
pill to swallow because our expectations
our opportunity cost is just so much
more affordable
from that beth mcgee avoiding montgomery
as well grab herbert couldn't agree more
in my man from at war damn michael
thomas will return and be a wide
receiver one i am happy to be well above
consensus on michael thomas right now he
is already in my top 20. anytime he
falls in round five or six go get him i
will say though thomas deandre hopkins
some of these guys with just the thing
still looming over their head you see
their drafted draft kind of volatility
bump up and down so keep that in mind
with these adps not always a given
depending on the draft you're in
pair of seattle seahawks running backs
up next everyone i got kenneth walker
and rashad penny on this list now
mentioned in the brief injury intro to
the show how rashad penny is back at
practice after dealing with the groin
injury as we've seen over the years
though not necessarily given he's going
to be out there the full time but for
now he seems healthy and then with
kenneth walker he unfortunately is
dealing with this hernia issue that
actually forced a procedure still
doesn't look like week one is
necessarily out of the picture it's not
a good start though i'd appreciate it if
kenneth walker wasn't having you know
procedures done on august freaking 17th
before the season starts but guys here's
the big problem in seattle it's not
kenneth walker and rashad penny it's
also dj dallas and travis homer these
you running backs that are going to
steal pass downs we've been told from
the beginning that they are going to
stay involved on pass downs they were
last season they were in the preseason
they're not going anywhere so now when
we look at kenneth and rashad it sounds
like penny should have the early chance
to start it would still be curious to me
if they completely just gave the
backfield over to penny and gave nothing
to kenneth walker i mean let's not
forget last year when penny was going
off at the end that came with chris
carson's sideline like we have seen them
historically would use multiple running
backs when they've had multiple running
backs healthy so not a given right now
but this is our best case scenario for
both these guys that they somehow take
the lead early down roll which is not a
given they don't catch passes because we
know we have dj dallas and travis homer
there they're playing they're working
behind pfs 32nd ranked offensive line
and if you guys wanted to call this the
single worst qb situation and probable
single worst offense in the league i
wouldn't disagree with you that's that's
the best case scenario that i just laid
out for you there the worst case is far
worse so i am staying far far away from
these seattle running backs they're
still going inside the top 90 players
give me guys like cordero patterson
kareem hunt chase edmonds and dallas
goddard in that range
from matt kareem best center saquon is
overrated he can be overrated man but if
he gets 350 touches this year like it's
looking like i don't think it's really
going to matter from at marcuse baker
i'm going with kenneth walker my dynasty
league thoughts yes that that's
completely different i'm talking read
draft only 2022 and i will say if you're
in a league where you have just single
keepers i think this is a great
opportunity to get kenneth walker i've
done some studies and running backs
drafted on day two from their first
season to their second season usually go
up on average nine spots at the running
back ranking so kenneth walker this year
might be going in round eight or nine
next year with just a single quarterback
change which lord knows you see enough
of those happen throughout this
offseason i think kendall walker could
be a consensus top five four round pick
by this time next year rashad petty's
gonna be a free agent so that's actually
like the main reason why i have walker
ranked one spot ahead of penny it's just
in the hope that if you are in a keeper
league i think you're gonna really have
a potential value there last year it was
javonte williams from trey sermon
standing out obviously one hit a little
bit better than the other one but again
kenneth walker just he does profile as a
special rusher it's just unfortunate
right now what he has to deal with for
this year
from at mg eckler or henry and ppr it's
a toss-up man i have been going with
derek henry i just think his best case
scenario if neither guy gets hurt i
think derek henry is the one that's
going to score more points have more
total touches and yeah eckler could do
it as well but you know when echoler is
probably gonna be capped at about 200
carries i just think that henry again if
our only if the only reason why we can't
draft someone is saying he's gonna get
hurt are we sure that derek henry is
more injury prone than austin necklace
it's not like eccler has exactly been
100 throughout his career either so i
think it's a little bit recently biased
there and real quick from iman thoughts
on the split between aaron jones and aj
dillon jones should be the future pass
catcher but man dylan's still going to
be involved too jones and dylan last
year each had four games with at least
40 receiving yards so dylan isn't a joke
as a receiver as well i want both
because unlike the next guy we're going
to get to if aaron jones or aj dillon
get hurt the other guy instantly falls
into the top five probably among all
running backs and even if they don't
jones can be an expected rb1 and i think
dylan could actually flirt with some
standalone value as a borderline rb2
like the roles between dylan josh jacobs
like antonio gibson these guys i think
they're actually a lot closer than
people think
it takes me to my next fade cleveland
brown running back nick chubb one of you
guys mentioned it before and i was just
talking about how the difference between
you know aaron jones and nick chubb is
if aj dylan gets hurt aaron jones
becomes the absolute workhorse if kareem
hunk gets hurt nothing really changes
from nick trump i don't know why this is
the case guys like don't shoot the
messenger please i love nick trump i
think he's probably the best real life
running back in the entire nfl but we're
not playing real life football we're
playing fantasy and last season nick
chubb had 17 and a half carries and
targets per game with kareem hunt and
17.6 carries and targets per game
without kareem hunt because they put the
ernest johnson in there on pass downs
instead of throwing the ball to nick
chubb and i understand it when it is
kareem hun out there like he's such a
special running back in his own right
and particularly as a pass catcher but
let's not pretend like nick chubb can't
catch a couple swing passes like just
get the dude in open space i saw dearest
johnson's you know underlying metrics
they're fantastic and you know as a as
an avid aaf xfl supporter and all that i
love the guy's journey but we're talking
about nick chubb here i don't understand
why we haven't seen more of an effort
you know from this coaching staff to
just really feature trump but it's the
reality and now that we have gotten news
that deshaun watson will be out for the
first 11 games of the season we're
talking about nick chubb in a not so
fantasy friendly role where he needs to
just continue to overly beast out on
rush attempts and not targets and an
offense that will likely take a step
back without deshawn watson on the field
for the first part of the season so to
me i'm drafting kareem hunt going
outside the top 30 running backs far
more often than chubb i think kareem has
served back to back low end rb2 seasons
and you could argue that he actually has
the higher ceiling if trump gets hurt as
opposed to chubb if hunk gets hurt so
with chum last four years in terms of
ppr points per game he's been the rb 24
11 7 and most recently 11 but last year
just the rb 21 expected ppr points per
game in 2020 he ranked 27. so it's
similar to debo sandal the talent is
there maybe they keep crushing it but at
these points in the draft i mean with
nick chubb going as the 16th player
overall i don't want to have workload
issues with my second round pick
from app tank nashi being overdrafted as
well
i agree with that in terms of the top
you know six running backs or so if you
throw album kamara ahead of him that's
fine as well but man it does get tough
when you look at someone like chubb and
naji trump's obviously better but is he
better is he going to outscore naji if
not he has an extra 100 touches on him
that's where it becomes a question from
avid praswa they're going to absolutely
run chubb into the ground i i hope so
man they haven't for two years i don't
know why we would expect that to change
uh from app bill mcgee bruce hall is
gonna be a beast i'm staying away from
michael carter the thing is man michael
carter's so affordable and michael
carter is going behind like just pure
handcuff guys like to me michael carter
and daryl henderson where they're going
in like the mid rb 40 range they have a
chance for standalone value obviously
breeze hall and cam makers are the
favorites to be the lead back but they
could have some standalone value it's
possible and both those guys carter and
daryl henderson have legit three down
handcuff appeal if something happens to
their team's respective starter two more
fades everyone cincinnati's bengals
quarterback joe burrow i work at pff i
live in cincinnati this one hurts me to
say but guys he's going off the board
now as the qb5 58th player overall
if you want to rank him as a top five
nfl quarterback at this point i think
you can last year number one in pff
passing grades second and quarterback
rating first in yards period attempt
third and adjust the completion rate
like pick a stat and you're going to see
how good joe burrow was the problem guys
it just comes back to volume and joe
burrow doesn't really have a fantasy
friendly variety like these dual threat
quarterbacks are just playing a
different game than the pocket passers
the same reason why we see the pass
catching running backs continuously rise
to the top of the fantasy ranks when you
have multiple means of getting
production it's really tough for guys
like joe burrow who are strictly
throwing the ball to be able to catch up
so for me when i see joe burrow at pick
58 what's the difference between joe
burrow and tom brady in my opinion like
okay if you want to put burrow ahead of
brady that's fine i
i think that's fair with that said
hold on my phone
all right one sec everyone
sorry about that quick mic fall out but
i am back with more joe bro goodness the
thing is guys zach taylor we did see
them actually feature joe burrow his
first year as a rookie before he got
hurt number one in drop backs actually
before he got injured last year though
and maybe because he was coming back
from the injury that's fair he's a
franchise quarterback one and bring him
back along but last year guys this was
the 30th ranked offense in pace and just
the 13th to make the offense and pass
play rate in neutral situations so last
season again joe burrow was the most
efficient quarterback in the league
anyone's idea of a top five real-life
quarterback and he still guys only had
one top five finish in weeks one through
15. ripped off a couple more after that
again the ceiling is there but i just
don't see a big enough difference
between joe burrow and tom brady who's
going 30 picks later and even if you
miss on tom brady matthew stafford kirk
cousins derek carr these are guys
regularly available deep into the
double-digit rounds of drafts that i
think are arbitrage enough versions of
joe burrow to feel good about it so joe
burrow for me is a fade as the qb5 i am
as my qb9 i would rather be drafting
guys like jalen hurts like trey lancy
even like kylo murray ahead of joe
burrow burro is the best real life one
again we are playing fantasy
from abdi thoughts on darren waller
darren waller
if he's going where he you know close to
dalton schultz i am absolutely fine with
him there i have seen kettle going
behind waller sometimes i will take
kittle in that scenario unfortunately we
just don't have the same sky-high
ceiling with waller anymore last year
the ceiling was the moon in terms of
targets with devonte adams there it's a
little bit tougher now
from s friedrich do you feel like goblin
can be the wide receiver one tampa bay
with a fully healthy season yes he would
be the wide receiver one inside
everyone's top 12 if we had no health
concerns i am also trying to be ahead of
the curve on goblin and michael thomas
goblin and michael thomas are legit
right now being priced still as wide
receiver threes the second we know
they're healthy probably top 15 top 20
at first but legit one good game we
could see them back into wide receiver
one territory like you're saying at
nick's underscore rule saquon or
fournette i have fournette one spot
ahead of saquon i think both are round
two round three running backs with round
one workloads so say juan or fournette
yes that's my answer uh s fell for he
mostly a top five running back this
season i had so much raheem moser and
saquon barkley best ball exposure last
season guys don't don't give me those
demons right there all right final fade
at adp the best quarterback in fantasy
football buffalo bills quarterback josh
allen my qb one he's going off the board
as the qb one the difference is he's my
37th player overall if you want to draft
josh allen you probably got to take him
at the end of the second round even
early round three 24th player overall it
really is incredible from just a
historical perspective what josh has
done being the overall qb1 each of the
past two seasons last guy to do that
2003 2004 dante culpepper doing his
thing if josh allen gets a third season
in a row as the overall fantasy qb won
he will join only
1992-94 steve young in 1995-97 brett
favre he's great we all know that but
there's a lot of great quarterbacks in
the nfl i'm not drafting any quarterback
at the end of round two or round three
when again we have jalen hurts lamar
jackson and kylo murray all available in
round six like when you're taking josh
allen here you're legit leaving
workhorse running backs and upside wide
receiver ones still on the board take
that player and get a slightly less
lesser version of josh allen literally
four rounds later take those freaking
quarterbacks in rounds five and six
while everyone else has taken the
antonio gibson's josh jacobs those dead
zone running backs of the world like
don't be afraid to really build that
strength whether it be running backs or
wide receivers early in your draft you
have time later to go get your
quarterback so again josh allen is my
qb1 if i said that on a you know tweet
people will be like oh yeah great of
course ian gets it but now if it's gonna
be ian's fading josh allen they're gonna
come at my head i'm fading the adp josh
allen is going at i believe you should
too
from avid person they're gonna
absolutely run nick chubb into the
ground we shall see my friend they
haven't so far from app philip
underscore clark damon harris or
stevenson and point five ppr it's
becoming stevenson i think i still have
damon harris one spot ahead
the it comes down to pass down role if
ty montgomery is gonna steal that pass
down roll which it certainly kind of
looks like it's gonna be tough that is
stevenson's path tyra kill wide receiver
one overall watch it could happen does
brandon cooks have a comeback year he's
never bounced back he's never has it
never has a down year man he had one
down you he'll have over a thousand
yards again and beat adp is it joe and
her season i would say the best
quarterback value relative to adp right
now what do you think about travis etm i
think worst case travis etienne is the
afc version of deandre swift best case
if something happens to james robinson
he will not leave the field and that's
going to be pretty pretty good guys uh
zeke or javonte williams give me javonte
williams pretty similar workloads at
this point a higher younger ceiling at j
martin d think kelsey becomes
significantly more valuable without
tyrique i think kelsey could have a
target total starting with two by the
time the season is over at heiser pick
trey lance or lamar it's lamar trey
lance guys and i've mentioned a couple
players like this which is the massive
disparity in adp and home leagues versus
like sharper leagues trey lance is going
qb7 a lot of best ball formats still
going qb 12 qb 13 in a lot of home
league so one of those things where i i
would almost like mock someone for
saying trey lance is their favorite late
round quarterback but if he's there he's
there so with that everyone my top 10
fancy stars to avoid ahead of 2022 based
on adp thanks again for tuning in i'm
ian hardis from pff until next time take
care
you